I've got a decent background but it's
always good to have a backup in case
there's a Messianic cessation of
happening on Zoom
that's Messianic cessation tell him the
story from last time fields
oh yeah I did I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
big time now but you take all the
responsibility that's also your problem
you should learn to delegate
well Eric knows how infrequently I
forget to record like that was the first
time and it was the time that he wasn't
here
yeah that's surprising you're usually on
your [ __ ] man what's going on it's
because you know Diego Diego makes me
nervous
he's got so many followers
because you're gonna have so much [ __ ]
in my background between an ax and like
a hype and Evangelion like I have a
confusing background look at this oh
yeah
yeah yours is very like realistic it's
kind of like
makes me feel like I'm laying in the in
the sofa of my psychoanal is looking at
the the ceiling which is the most scary
thing you can look at it's the the
partial object like the blank screen
yeah all right with that
don't know if we're gonna use that but
anyway wait what number are we on 95
welcome listener you are on pillpod
number 95.
we have lost a member to Europe he went
he went
where I don't know where he is right now
Germany
um
shout outs to Victor but we have uh so
he's got some some big feet filling his
shoes here and it's again Mr Diego
who is our he makes this a True North
American podcast
from Mexico I'm so proud to be here I'm
a big fan of the podcast of the pill
pods to be honest with you guys and I
also have to add that even if Victor is
currently in Germany depending on what
time you're listening to this podcast
maybe after World War III is the is the
is the larger Republic of North China or
the potential uh longer Republic of new
NATO or something like that we'll see
depending on when you're listening to
this yeah exactly everything's up in the
air over there or somebody land two or
something like that we don't know yeah
coming you from before the apocalypse
yeah you guys just dig this out of the
dust and it suddenly it's a pure part
about Spinoza I'm sorry to disappear
Point there's nothing here to rebuild
civilization
yeah so I mean we have variously plans
ideas uh Diego and I got in an argument
on on a Twitter live space about
materialism we might pick that up
um Diego and Eric are both really into
Walter Benjamin we might pick that up
but at least the general thread that is
not yet woven into any sort of tapestry
is the episode title which I'm sure
you've seen God and communism
and we don't know where it's going to go
it's going to be off the cuff yeah hey
yo
how do you guys want to set this up
what's the intro here
I guess I guess because I picked the I
picked the topic
um based on those different arguments we
we I guess we we weren't arguing with
each other so much as arguing with other
people there are other disembodied
voices yeah exactly um but it's it was
uh I uh we're kind of arguing about
dualism and materialism
PLO versus ideology and you were kind of
lumping religion into ideology we don't
want to be too heavy-handed I don't
think because with the label with the
Lord heavy-handed is not which Lord the
hand the hand of the market yeah which
the invisible hands Lord of lords King
of Kings the invisible reach around God
of gods yeah
yeah but yeah I guess if you've seen my
content lately it's been bending towards
uh Theology of capitalism which was uh
my latest video and then Edward Bernays
so Freud's nephew this is maybe we'll
start with this Freud's nephew Edward
Bernays was
hired by uh Alan Dulles when he was the
director of the CIA in the 50s to
pretty much just wage psychological
warfare on the people of Guatemala and
Americans and he set up this whole
advertising campaign
um Distributing leaflets and and post
are writing in in the New York Times I
believe and Time Magazine and he set up
this giant psychological War called God
or communism and the idea was our Benz
is a communist which he wasn't but our
Benz is a communist because he's trying
to nationalize the United Fruit Company
land in Guatemala and you have to make a
choice as the as the hearer of this
propaganda you have to make a choice are
you going to take the side of God and
Christianity or are you going to take
the side of the Godless communist and of
apparently our Benz is a Soviet agent
which he was not but this was the story
they told and it was successful in being
able to produce
support right popular support in both
America and in Guatemala for cooing our
bends and sending him to Exile so anyway
that's the back story why I thought hey
God versus communism how to what extent
are these reconciled or reconcilable and
maybe we can just kick it off from there
yeah you forgot to mention yeah uh God
Christianity and capitalism
they sometimes go hand in hand they tend
to go hand I think I I think so but you
know bernay's didn't he also do
something with Dole fruit too he's the
guy who worked with the United Fruit
Company and the Banana Republic thing
came out of bernay's kind of uh shock
treatment of and despite this
Christianity versus communism thing he
was Jewish so
yeah and he also worked with this this
modern notion of the American breakfast
as well which when I was working with
the food industry I got in touch with
some of his work and how he originally
changed um you know that basically
Americans are so heavy on cereal in the
morning because of a campaign they did
with Kellogg's introducing this notion
that corn flakes was a fundamental part
of breakfast which caused a mass
disaster of diabetes like giving a point
to our friend Marx again and why I'm why
I'm saying by saying this let's say by
the Orthodox Marxist tradition the
dialectical materialism is very
simplistically saying is an ocean that
material basis or the material
conditions of the world creates or
produces idealistic superstructures or
this notion of the superstructures and
my reading in the in the Tweet space
that got controversial uh appeals is
that my current reading of Spinoza
applied to my dialectical materialism is
that there's no real dialectical
retractivism a retractive feed Cycles
between the super structural
the superstructural ideas and the
material basis and and my notion being
very monistic about this reading is that
everything that we understand as
subjectivity ideology theology it's
symptomatic it's not dialectic it's
symptomatic what we can do is use
critical theory tools to in a way dig
through the mud and see the relationship
between the symptoms and the causes but
the causes are in a in in a more Spinoza
way uh within a system uh within uh you
know this substance that is just showing
itself in in various forms and modes but
in the end everything that is idealistic
everything that is in the ideal world
it's symptomatic to the material world
but there's no there's no retractive
symptom there's no there's no way for
the symptom to retroactively change the
material conditions
so it sounds like oh to me what you're
saying then is that monism doesn't
Encompass both materialism and idealism
that idealism is almost like a surface
effect yep it's almost like a I don't
know if I want to bring up this word Epi
phenomenon it's a surface effect and
there's a one-way causal relationship
yep something like that
okay okay I see that I tend to like to
try and expand monism if I'm thinking
that way to include ideas and ideology
but maybe that's not the right way I
should be uh approaching it I don't know
bills this was the starting point no
this was the context in which we started
this conversation yeah and I would love
to hear your guys point of view about
this because I'm truly trapped in this
idea right now is is not it's not a
straw man that I'm painting from myself
this is truly where I stand in the sense
that uh I don't know if Eric if you know
but my wife is a lakhanian psychoanalyst
and she is practicing like she has over
30 patients so I I've read lacano of my
life I've read Freud all my life uh I
started in in philosophy because of my
son's disease into capacism into this
notion of uh the excluded orders that
are not able to produce and then I got
into the Marxist tradition because of
that and now after all this reading I
got into this notion that even if I
understand the value of psychoanalysis
another methodological tools for us to
understand the idealistic word world in
the the end and and also in action I see
that more and more idealism is nothing
more than a symptom from the material
conditions I did I did listen to the
last episode you're on so this sounds
very familiar to me and I very much
sympathize with that approach and it
seems like that the angle that I kind of
take if you're familiar with what I look
at sometimes is like biosemiotics and
some new research you know when they
when they talk about gut health and
things like that right there's a
materialistic basis even there where
we're deepening our understanding of how
our attitudes and how our moods and our
emotions and our ideas are affected by
our gut health and what we eat and yeah
our bodily Constitution really affects
our ways of thinking as well and you
know how can you have a revolution on
empty stomachs and and uh Kellogg's Corn
Flakes you just can't do it I was I was
just having this conversation last week
actually last week I so you guys see I'm
also in practice and not only in theory
I'm not fake to my own beliefs I I
organized last week at Congress in
Mexico City that we call confluencia
it's Confluence and I brought some
friends that are philosophers most of
them phds from Spain and Argentina to
think about an iberophonic identity so
what does it mean to speak Spanish and
Portuguese since the two languages are
the only two languages in the world that
share a 99 compatibility and are based
on the verbs
which means to do and to be which are
very materialistic and we were even
discussing how German and English are
very idealistic languages because the
subject is always implied and he's
implied in a metaphysical sense and
Spanish and Portuguese this subject only
is in action
you know the subject only is when he's
doing and and we were having these
conversations in Spanish about the
materialistic tradition and what we can
do with the materialistic tradition in
Spanish that maybe was not able to be
done in other in other cultures in other
moments in the world than in other
languages for sure
all right so if uh are you saying like
in English and and German lends itself
towards a theological metaphysics yes
the very material condition of the
sounds and the structure of the language
itself tends to idealism how does the
how does French fit in with these
between the two it's also very romantic
but I think the metaphysical subject in
French structure is different I mean I'm
not that fluent in French even if I can
read it and I can kind of speak it it
tends to more the the Romantic route to
the to the Roman uh to the Roman root
but specifically Spanish and Portuguese
the verb is always Super Active like the
subject is is acting all the time is
doing he's doing in the world you know
he's not implied as a metaphysical
subject
okay so if we're asking a question kind
of like we opened up with what is God
what is God for
um there's many this is maybe two Stu
it's too stupid or stupid to try to deal
with this in an hour but uh the argument
that you made I noticed was
only about causality it wasn't about the
personality of God it wasn't about
um you know whether God loves us cares
for us or uh the utility of religion for
like social cohesion or anything like
that the only thing you care about it
seems like is causality yeah cause of
itself and not
dialectical causality no like pure pure
difference cause of itself causality so
well if someone's like offended because
they believe in in God and it's a part
of their identity and part of their
religious community
you don't care
I don't I don't care about offended
people they don't bring much the
discussion to be honest
oh sorry no I didn't want to interrupt
you I was just not I don't think
dialecticism has to apply dualism does
it okay good can we start from there
what's what's a monistic dialectics how
do you differentiate one thing from the
other you know money's point of view
having dialectic as a relative
difference
when I when I listen to uh the sort of
arguments that the zhijekians for
example present against Spinoza Spinoza
and Spinoza's influenced post-humanism
they will say you know let's we got to
start with Descartes
and Descartes famously introduces this
dualism right you have substance dualism
you have mind on the one side matter on
the other side or substance and they
then travel forward in time to to Hegel
who
uh maybe I'm gonna I'm gonna botch this
because I haven't I haven't looked it
over lately
but
the questioning of the subject the
critique of the subject was completed
during German idealism for them and now
this new assault that is coming from
post-humanism developing a monistic
standpoint is just repeating this kind
of gesture that has already been
completed that's that's one of that's
like a very simplified version of what
they sometimes say
and so I I kind of read that as as
dialecticism doesn't imply dualism
because you're not starting with this
dualistic ontology you're starting with
the thesis antithesis but you don't want
to say antithesis because the antithesis
comes from within the thesis it's not
something external to the thesis that's
that's basically what I mean the thesis
develops into the antithesis through the
second stage the negative dialectic
stage
that's how I put it that's that's really
confusing but it's it seems to say that
it's not dualistic in in the in the
Cartesian sense anyway
are you going to comment something pills
or can I no I please respond please so
so there's a there's a text that I
looked up for this from a guy named
Wilfred uh cantwell's myth I don't know
if you guys heard about him before
uh he has a book called the meaning and
the end of religion and I just want to
read something very very quick so first
like the the notion of the book is that
uh religion is an aerocentric term
and normally what you have to do is that
you have to secularize the meaning of
religion in order to apply the category
of religion to somebody that is
religious okay and this this is this is
this is what for me causes a lot of this
confusion because for people that are
true religious they're not religious for
them religion is ontology
I don't know if I don't know if this is
explaining it clear enough in the sense
that you know for a Buddhist Buddhism is
not a religion it's a world view
you have you have you need the
secularized reading of the word religion
in order to apply religion as a category
to religion itself so religion only
makes sense from a secularized point of
view from religion you see like
the word religion already implies that
religion is ideology
and going back to Marx with this because
if we're if we're orthodoxists with the
reading is that
uh the material bases create the the
ideal superstructures but ideal
superstructures exist not only to mask
the material bases but to but to prepare
perpetuate them in order to maintain the
stability of the material bases that
produces the idea the idealistic
superstructures so in that sense what is
interesting for me and and I would love
to have Eric's take on this because this
will take us closer to Benjamin okay is
the sense of what is the function of
religion like we can already pretty much
admit that religion is symptomatic like
religion religion doesn't create the
world the world creates religion no and
this is this is the electrical
materialism where the ideas don't create
the world the world creates ideas so in
that sense even religion is a
consequence of past material conditions
that produce these World Views and and
what is important for people listening
to the discussion is that when you
already use the word religion to
describe religious practice and
religious belief you're you're making a
swift of a the movement of hands and by
switching a religious point of view that
is ontological there is a notion of the
world is a world view and you're
treating it as as a sub uh sub category
of belief so it's already ideological so
if that sense for me it's already
ideology so for me the the real question
is not is not what comes before we
already have established that material
conditions come before what I'm
interested in is arguing whether or not
religions dialectically change the world
or not
and this of course will take us into the
field of free will because in the end
how much of our consciousness of our
subjectivity interpretation of Free Will
is able to alter back material
conditions
he's almost uh you've paraphrased Marx
very closely there actually uh
right near the beginning you said the
world creates religion uh the it's the
you've paraphrased paraphrased Marx very
closely here the the human being makes
religion religion does not make the
human being the religion is the
self-consciousness and self-esteem of
the human
I'm less I'm triple-centric than Marx I
think Marx was a was a crypto humanist
and that's probably the problem I mean
as the same way people criticize
enough we can maybe even even say that
Marx was not Marxist enough in the sense
that I think Marx still carries an
anthropocentric
um
uh bias that is no longer necessary
that's why I think I paraphrase it
because I remember the sentence but I
don't completely agree with it I don't
think I don't think uh what was Mark's
way
humans don't create religion uh yeah the
the human this is from 1844 so he's
still in his kind of disalienation phase
but yeah you're right so that is really
a crypto humanist either it was pretty
much an explicit explicitly yeah
he was really young he was 20 28 when he
wrote 1844 yeah the human being makes
religion religion does not make the
human being religion is the
self-consciousness and self-esteem of
the human who has either not yet won
through to himself or has already lost
himself again so human human-centric
yeah right anthropocentric here and he
also calls it I mean people use this to
criticize Marx but he also says you know
it's the opiate of the people which I
think is
it's misunderstood because we think
opiate means oh it's something bad but
it's like opiate is is a painkiller
because it's the heart of the heartless
world so he's not he's not explicitly
[Music]
um anti-theist I think he thinks that
religion is important but also it serves
this ideological function at the same
time to be the Salve so that you know
you don't need to change your material
conditions yeah it has a kind of
anesthetizing effect because it's an
expression of suffering but it creates
an inverted world one that reflects the
material world but in inverted form just
as Hegel is sort of needing to be turned
on his head because he gives us an
inverted idealistic dialectic whereas
Marx is going to give us a materialistic
dialectic right absolutely yeah so here
here's where it's get interesting to me
because taking Marxism seriously and if
you try to be a serious dialectical
materialist you either have to become
theological in the sense that uh Marxism
becomes Messianic
things you know like there's a logic to
material conditions and there's an
endpoint resolution to these antagonisms
that will eventually take us to the
culmination of History so there's a
poetic messianism implied in the very
Orthodox reading of Marx and on the
other hand you need to be completely uh
away from self-determinism you need to
be completely at a heart determinist
because if in in Reading Spinoza again
okay so the notion of Liberty from
freedom from Espinoza is freedom is the
subjective ignorances of the causes that
conditions so we're only free as much as
we don't understand the previous causes
that conditions our Notions of Freedom
right so we're only free in in as much
as we don't understand the relationships
of of costs that provoke our notion of
freedom but if you apply that notion of
freedom to Marxism then the only way to
be a truly uh a dielectric material is
is to be hard determinist
so there's so there's no so there's no
room for the the second part of the
dialectic to come down from from
superstructures to material bases
that's that's the kind of Spinoza's
argument because we as as we grow in
knowledge we learn what causes things
what determines things and so our growth
and knowledge brings determinism into
play but through that there's a
paradoxical Freedom that comes around
with knowing determinism is that is that
right maybe I've maybe I've butchered
that a little bit
well
the best explanation I've heard about
this this uh the definition of freedom
from Spinoza is that you're standing in
front of two doors A and B and you
choose to Open Door B okay and you open
door B and you feel happy that you went
through Derby but the issue is that door
a was always locked and you never tried
so you have this notion of Freedom based
on your your bodily experience of the
world and you tell yourself the story of
freedom because you don't understand the
limitations of the material world in the
same way that we think there's a certain
degree of freedom from our actions but
we don't understand all the microbiome
decision making that is taking place
prior to subjectivity that condition our
notion of freedom
yeah I think I like that that's
complexity Theory as well today right we
we just sort of retroactively project
free choice onto our decisions yeah
after the fact
after the fact I was free to choose door
B and the first I could have chosen a
so are you saying are you you're making
a determinist case more or less here I
know our determinist
ah [ __ ] don't put me there I don't know
man okay because in when we're dealing
with like Spinoza's substance it's not
clear that we're talking about
the way we conceive materialism that's
why it's called Spinoza's God it's not
necessarily material yep
um
but I guess the ignorance of of not
knowing what we had chosen
it I don't I don't necessarily think
that it leads to determinism necessarily
because you wouldn't know either way
so so you think there's freedom in
mistakes
there's act I believe it I I would
believe that there's accidents in a sort
of spinozan universe that could be I
agree they could be called freedom I
agree there's and it's it's not the
freedom of like an individual human
subject I think all of us are past that
in this conversation yep but the
accident we're not liberals come on man
don't insult me like that the liberal
subject
what I would say is like nature itself
can make what we'd call Accidents yeah
or or causeless causeless effects that's
why that's unclear effects that's why I
would not commit to this notion of hard
determinism because I think there's
still some potentiality you know this
difference between freedom from and
freedom too that I I still there's still
room for newness but newness is not
experience or I mean newness is not
provoked
by the ideal uh subject that is acting
upon the material world but newness is
creative retroactively as our
subjectivity signifies what happened
after it has already taken place and
maybe by accident or by lack of
information we influence the outcome of
a given point in in time and we provoke
newness but it doesn't necessarily
correspond to what we wanted to do to
what we understood and to the current
limitations of the material world you
know it's signifying after it has
already happened
and you know ideological superstructure
as a kind of surface effect attempts to
grasp the material causes but it doesn't
cause those causes those causes cause it
but that's what we grasp them through in
a certain sense exactly my point Eric
yeah I think I think you you were able
to explain my position better than
myself yeah and I like this this notion
that yes I idealism is how we explain
the world but you see is like
secularizing the notion of religion to
call religion something else that is not
ontology
yeah this is a point we kind of move
past very quick but I think it's
actually very important and it's really
Nietzsche's
big contribution to the to the
philosophy well values as soon as as
soon as something is of value which
means it's relative and not necessary
and God didn't invent it then you don't
believe it anymore so as soon as
religion is something that you can
choose off the shelf if you go into the
marketplace of religions and say uh I
think I think I'm leaning towards Daoism
as soon as you get to choose now you are
no longer a religious person now you are
basically a consumer of an idea
structure the marketplace of ideas yeah
you see check this out
um I'm just going to read a part of it
even more strikingly Smith notes that
ancient Egyptians Iranian Aztecs Chinese
Japanese Indian Indonesian Greeks and
Hebrews did not possess indigenous words
for religion
yeah you see religion is a word that was
brought from Europe to these other
countries and Europe called them
religious yeah you know and and what we
have to understand historically most of
these of these uh cultures the religious
word was the same as law
it was it was a synonym you know that if
it was in the Scriptures it was law it
was a world view it was not religion as
we understand it today yeah there's no
sacred texts in ancient Greece no not
hesia not Homer they're not sacred texts
they're just stories embodied and
whatever whoever wrote them he said
writes a poem a theogony it's not
there's no Dogma there's no there's no
Central set of beliefs that you have to
prescribe to and so it's actually a
little bit like medieval of Christianity
was before the high Middle Ages when it
all got kind of the centralized and
assimilated into a set of beliefs then
you get a dogma and if you don't stick
to that Dogma you're persecuted
to return to this Spinoza God I'm sure
you know the delays reading of Spinoza
right yeah I have the book I have the
book right here yeah so if if we have I
mean that
you're making the hard determinist case
a little bit and his way out of that I
think would be to say that what what you
actually observe I think what you're
calling material or the settled world
something like that what you actually
observe is not how things had to be
because reality is both virtual and
actual differentiating
so just because something is a certain
way it didn't have to be that way and
that's why this notion of accident and
difference and repetition exactly why
difference is still in what we see and
observe as actual so that would be a way
to reintroduce the possibility of
accident and contingency and like Eric
was talking about him and I agree on
this point in terms of uh complexity
Theory complexity leads to complexity
and the difference that makes a
difference
yeah cybernetic virtual yeah I I think
that that's that's why I really love
your your latest readings of capitalism
in these more uh machine like
um you know but but also there's a
there's a theological aspect to the
machine-like behavior but in the same
sense that we we are ourselves unable to
judge our worldview as ideological you
know I think it's the same criticism
that that uh Freud did to the critics of
psychoanalysis that people tend to to
use and understand psychoanalysis on
other people but not on themselves is is
as if we are resilient to judge Our
World Views as ideological as well in
that but but in the Marxist tradition
like in the Marxist reading in the sense
that your worldview it's a product of
your material conditions and you if we
are strict to that what we can what we
can say even to Marxism is that the
relationship between Marxism and
theology
it's also dependent on the material
conditions that allow us to make that
interpretation in the first place
because otherwise it will imply us being
in a in a
what is the name of this uh punto like
at this point outside like as if we were
standing outside of ideology judging
ideology from space you know archimedia
exactly is is as if we're taking an
archimedium point to be the
unideological readers of ideology which
is like that's impossible I mean if
you're serious about Marxism your points
of view are also ideological but but I
think ideology because of this maybe was
given this very negative connotation but
but in the end for me the the problem
and this is the central point of the
conversation I wanted to have with you
guys is that religion before the
European invasion
was also ideology and worldview ontology
is ideological in the sense that
material condition produces ideological
points of view from the world
yeah now you're now we're going into
semiotics which is
you're you're somewhere some are both
very comfortable actually
um but yeah the the fact that you can
believe something while knowing that it
is a sign part of the science system
that is uh I don't really like using the
word determined myself but it does
Define the channels of possibility yep
within your specific science system and
I think this is interesting in terms of
when you're speaking of religion because
one of the stories that I
I don't know if it's true or not but I
like I like repeating it is that this
whole Buddhism is a way of life thing as
opposed to a religion was a colonial
interaction when the Christians are you
know
getting all over the world and the
Buddhists there say this isn't a
religion don't worry like we're this is
a way of life thing you don't need to
come kill us we're not we're not Pagan
priests just a way of life thing which
is like what you're saying this
interaction between
the Christian monolith the the
monolithic religion that says everything
else is a demonic perversion of
Christianity if it's not Christianity
paganism which creates a it's a it's a
dialectic inversion of all others are
even this manichaean framework which
isn't an invention of uh Christianity of
course yeah you're religious we're right
yes you have the wrong one
yeah we do have that that problem
sometimes though and this was like a big
event on like what theory tube uh when
that theory tuber was explaining cons
and I think it was Hans Georg Mueller he
did a he did a review of his explanation
of Kant and he said this guy's
completely confused Transcendent with
transcendental Transcendent is that
place where God lives you know God
freedom of freedom and immortality of
the Soul that's Transcendent
transcendentalism is a weird sort of in
between right it's the it's points more
towards subjectivity and the and the
categories and logic as opposed to the
Transcendent which is what is just by
definition beyond what we can experience
we can't experience the Transcendent we
I I don't know how you get there it's
super sensible it's only it's only in
thought it's only in rationality at
least this is I'm just sort of spouting
out some content stuff there but
it's a it's reasonable because gig does
hold to this right he's a he's a
transcendentalist in a certain way he
just has also his theory of ontological
incompleteness that goes along with it
so when you encounter a contradiction
that's because the structure of reality
has contradiction written into it
I would love to bring to bring if we can
at some point A friend of mine from
Spain called Ernesto Castro he's fluent
in English as well PhD the guy teaches
Aesthetics in the University of
Salamanca no not Salamanca or Madrid I
think he's in right now and like his
notion of Aesthetics your guy will
simply adore like he's super into
Mauritius like his notion of Aesthetics
is is very much in line of what we
understand as a statistics I think and
the guy uh we we recorded a podcast last
week and he was explaining to me the
seven definitions of Freedom basis based
on the 70 shift definitions of love from
the platonic dialogues
it was incredible like his work is
[ __ ] fantastic the guy's brilliant
but I would love to get into this notion
in this conversation because in the end
what I think that the big conundrum is
in this conversation and since like I
think most of my friends in the in the
academic world are either Marxist but or
materialist which is kind of hard
because now like if you're leftist and
you're not Marxist I don't trust you if
you're leftists and your Marxist but
you're not materialist I don't trust you
at all you know it's like it's kind of
weird because it tends to push push you
to this notion that the enemy is
idealism
um and it's messed up because when when
you get to when you get to materialism
my problem is determining the role of
freedom in materialism you know it's
exactly what is the what is the right
level of Freedom how do we understand
freedom from a monist materialist point
of view that is non-dialectical
because the whole the whole notion of
dialectics implies
Concepts that are or or entities that
are cause of themselves
because to be dialectical beyond the
beyond the idealistic part of of of
dialectics if you want to be dialectical
materialist
without the Spinosa point of view that
there's no uh entities that are cause of
themselves beyond the one substance how
is dialectics taking place if everything
is intertwined what do you mean the
electrical in the sense that how is one
thing disconnected from the rest that it
can be the cause of something else
so are you you're making an argument
against dialectics again yes have you
heard of something called negative
theology no is is the adornal one known
that's negative dialectics but negative
theology actually goes back to like the
the early church fathers and like the
the third Century but negative theology
is a theology without the dialectics
because the only thing you cannot say
anything true about God you cannot make
any proposition about God because God is
eternal Transcendence so the only thing
you can say about God are negative
statements
God is not limited God is Not finite so
it really it reduces the dependency of
religion and and like theology on
language it just says the only true
things you can say about God are
negative statements which that's
interesting I mean in terms of uh
theology that I like to read it's the
the one that I'm partial to because it's
the only one that can be right you know
yeah it's sort of like um
oh yeah or not wrong at least I wish
you're not making false statements but
it's not possible negative epistemology
I'm not wrong I think that's sort of
what Augustine is thinking about a
little bit like God if God fills
everything then wears Freedom he sort of
inhales a little bit like sucks in sucks
his belly in and leaves a little bit of
room there or something like that like
that kind of a metaphor for negative
feel he just evacuates a little bit so
say anything positive about God then
that would be to create difference but
you can't create difference in God
because there is no difference in God
God is everything he's infinite
yeah so can we can we talk about the
instrumental use of religion in Marxism
and maybe go go there because there's
two readings we can have the reading
that the one you said at the beginning
saying that um uh religion was also
almost antagonical to communism because
of course in a sense uh some branches of
of Marxism leninism were uh atheists but
also there's uh Walter Benjamin there's
other readers of social Christians
socialist Christians that have found a
way to
to make the two the two schools of
thought copulate and and coexists which
I find very hard to believe in like I
find it hard to believe for an
idealistic point of view to coexist with
a materialist transition either either
you stand from a point of view and you
say Okay dialectical materialism is
Messianic so since the electrical
materialism is Messianic I can choose
what other narrative or whatever
literature I want to overcoat and paint
over material dialectic materialism to
help me tell the story in a way that
people will will empathize with you know
it's like Eric was saying I just choose
like a painting a coating of paint to
put over the electrical materialism
because there's a bunch of cogs and
mechanisms going under that we don't
fully understand but responds to uh to
an internal system of logic which is
dialectical materialism and we paint
over it Judaism christianism such as
whatever whatever story you want to tell
but but it's a very laid back position
because you're just waiting for story to
unfold
sorry where are we going with that
comparing this comparing this like being
a Marxist and having some theological
background and and being a Marxist and
being fully fully atheist but also being
a determinist because right you have to
commit to this idea of the electrical
materialism well there's a few I mean
just to like give the give the options
on the Shelf here you can there's like
socialist Jesus is one version of this
like Jesus is a socialist revolutionary
before the before the Advent or like
religion is a useful tool for getting
buy-in which is a rather I guess kind of
cynical view that we can use religion to
organize but we don't really believe it
you know
um and then there's like or the
psychoanalytic approach like we need to
believe in some higher power to be able
to like believe in ourselves so it's a
again a cynical humanist argument I'm
kind of partial to the cynical humanist
argument actually yeah I don't believe
we're really free but we kind of need to
believe we're free to get things exactly
yeah
um but you're you're making an argument
about strictly speaking uh metaphysics
yeah right okay what do you think
I mean there's there's so many ways I
want to go with it in a in a way I I
like the the negative theology approach
because I do want to make room for
spiritualism in Marxism I think it is
just practical to say you know okay
there is Christian socialism it is a
valid position just really practically
speaking saying there's a huge swath of
people out there like in an earlier
episode when Matt was speaking with um
uh Aaron I think his name was from uh
from the ICS from The Institute for
Christian socialism that many people are
driven out of away from their faith
because it's been you know colonized by
republicanism and really like right-wing
views so I think just practically
speaking I don't know I go I'll try to
get back to Theory but I mean just
practically speaking we need that we
need we need to be able to say if you
have some kind of Faith whatever it is
Judaism Christianity Islam there's room
for you in a socialist movement
but how we take that then back to Marx's
work and say okay well here's where you
know like it's the Opium of the people
isn't to say it's a bad thing we've
already kind of established that right
it's an expression of suffering and
that's the key word it's it's expressive
so it is it is ideological and in that
sense it has a kind of anesthetizing
effect suffering is at the heart of
religion and our suffering makes us into
Believers and and believing helps us
deal with that suffering just as you
know psychoanal analysis tries to death
psychology tries to look inwards and see
that those sources of suffering
yeah I'm gonna quote probably one of my
favorite philosophers and thinkers of
all time and say do ideas matter
that's yeah that's the problem right if
I if ideas are simply caused by material
circumstances not simply actually very
complexly caused by material
circumstances then
then what good is it but it depends on
how you make you feel right it's it's an
effective kind of
we have to be in the realm of affect
what what
what purse would call the firstness
right affect influences first of all and
it's and it's getting to reality because
reality is that thing right ideas don't
matter to reality because he defines it
as reality is what exactly what it
doesn't matter what you or I or any
number of people think about it reality
is reality itself
but there is still an effective approach
there's still so it makes us feel things
yeah so my question is specifically in
that end of the loop so so we're saying
that there's um there's a material
condition that produces ideas and how
these ideas feedback into the cycle of
changing material conditions of changing
reality that's that's my my question is
there like when do exactly and how does
exactly ideas and understanding that
ideas are caused either completely or by
mistake or by misinterpretation or by
some sort of openness that is potential
how do they feed back into the cycle and
change the world
because ideas come built in with the
possibility that you are wrong that you
are mistaken that you are not grasping
it properly because we know that ideas
are exactly what allow us to grasp the
material basis but then ideas come baked
in with with
you have to be fallible in your approach
because if you take ideas as simply
causing reality or causing the material
base then you're approaching something
like fascism or totalitarianism in your
thinking and that and then that's not no
that's that is not conducive to the to
moving forward into kind of some kind of
revolutionary Consciousness
revolutionary subjectivity that's
fascism yeah and on that point I I never
someone to say you can't believe that
because it's wrong I don't I don't even
think honestly that you can say that and
know that you're correct in saying that
somebody else is wrong
um but on your point this is going to be
the most post-modern thing I say today
um one of one of the top top 10.
to to it's not always effective in terms
of like cause and effect
especially in a social situation to be
correct and I'll use Nietzsche here
because Nietzsche talks about the use of
Truth
and how our use of Truth is so violent
that it makes us wither so he talks
about if you if you pull away the
Horizon if you pull away someone's
capacity to believe in something
including yourself if you if you say I I
shall not go any further than this and I
refuse to believe because I refuse to be
wrong you suck out the air of the
atmosphere is what he says and you've
become this withered little plant
because
for us whether it's stupid whether it's
right or wrong meaning is
a dimension of space for us
we need to have the opportunity to have
ideology to give meaning to give meaning
to our ourselves to give our experience
to history the thesis on History we need
we need it to matter even if we're wrong
about it and I think it might be more
important that it matters than that it's
correct yeah it's almost like saying
like the story is important even if the
story was not true
if you can do this do you mind
explaining the the automata example from
Walter Benjamin and theology being
hidden under the table
it's a tall order
um let's see
let's see the story told of an automaton
constructed in such a way that it could
play winning game of chess okay I gotta
refresh my memory of the of this a
puppet in Turkish attire
sat before a chessboard why doesn't have
to be in Turkish attire
you will see okay
so there's a little there's a little
Hunchback he's an expert chess player
and he's and he's hidden under the table
and through a system of mirrors he's
able to play the game
and it looks like it looks like the game
is playing itself it looks like there's
an automaton sitting in front of it is
that is is that the basic thing the
puppet is historical materialism correct
and it must enlist the service of
theology in order to in a sense justify
its moves
and then and so Benjamin sets up this
this again I'll I'll say I'll say it
it's a dialectic in a certain sense
right between Theology and historical
materialism
but there's another player in this game
it's historicism and this goes back to
the this goes back to the the sort of
contextual argument right there's
there's
historicism is coming out of social
democracy and the social Democrats are
somebody that Marx was a little bit
upset with in the good the program
because they were capitulating to the
Bourgeois in their ideas they had these
false ideas about Labor
but I don't know how far I could go with
this because it's you know I came I I
came to Benjamin through the task of the
translator and writing on his earlier
stuff
and then you get the cultural
materialism you get the cultural
materialism of of say
Raymond Williams and the British new
left who pick up Benjamin and and they
pick up uh Antonio gramci in order to
talk about why the revolution fails
because they're not paying attention to
the cultural they're not paying
attention to that ideological
superstructure because they are
reductive they're not that and that was
a distinction I didn't I wanted to bring
up like being a determinist doesn't mean
you're a reductionist correct it doesn't
mean you're reducing everything to an
economic basis a materialistic basis it
simply means that
well
if you take a complexity view you can be
a non-reductive determinist and
[Music]
maybe maybe you can maybe someone else
should carry it on from there because
that that puppet is historical
materialism and the dwarf and the dwarf
is Theology and the dwarf is Theology
and the dwarf in a sense is the
ideological superstructure that
retroactively justifies the moves and
gives the gives meaning but then again
what I think is cool about this this
image that is being painted by by
Benjamin is that um theology acts
through the electrical materialism on
the world on the chest and also there's
a there's a teleological uh reading of
this story like
um
this notion that history has a purpose
you know history has an end point has a
has a mission to be fulfilled and and
it's interesting in a practical sense I
think uh theology can be
instrumentalized
to fulfill the purpose of dialectical
materialism as in this story from
Benjamin but also as Marx warned us
theology can be instrumentalized to stop
the motion of the electrical materialism
as in the Opium of the people so I think
these are the two complex readings that
we have to give that sometimes religion
helps people find class Consciousness or
uh understand their position in the
world as all the ones being uh alienated
from from their own selves and from work
and whatnot but also theology can help
with the Messianic point of view as
being this uh complex system
closed causal Loop of determination that
yes there's a there's a course of
history that is resolving antagonisms
that are presented in in given moments
in time that will eventually solve
themselves and and produce the future
produce the new
so you want to maintain kind of the
first thing you said there and get rid
of the second thing is that to be honest
I don't completely know I think to be
honest with you I I'm more leaning
towards the second one in the sense that
uh I think we use theology to help us
understand the the the point in history
in which we get in contact with with the
with the process of psychological
materialism but in the end when we look
back at them we're going to secularize
them all and and I'm scared that even
some ontological or metaphysical
questions that we use today to to cover
over the work of dialectical materialism
is going to be eventually look back upon
with a categories such as religion
oh you fear that oh yeah I think we're
gonna look back at this point moment in
time and say oh my God they were so full
of themselves and so ideological but
they were acting as they were as if they
were outside of ideology
well this is the battle there's a
there's almost a Master Slave Dynamic
going on right Papa implies a kind of
slavery right and so the theology uses
materialism but materialism can also use
Theology and and and the Theses kind of
enacts that shifting motion right if if
historical materialism can get on top
and use theology to its own ends as
opposed to theology being on top and and
and using itself to justify the material
conditions like Benjamin thought
you know Benjamin thought Carl Jung was
was quite fascist in his thinking and I
think that goes towards one of the
readings of Freud is that it's used to
normalize people who have you know
neuroses psychosis
it's a way of it's a way of um reigning
back those neuroses and then normalizing
them and and setting them back into
capitalism and say okay now you can be a
productive member of society because
you've gotten on top of your neuroses as
opposed to you know accepting the fact
that Neurosis is a is a fundamental part
of subjectivity Eric that was [ __ ]
beautiful man that's that was
beautifully put and I'm glad pills is
back [ __ ] I missed it no no this is
perfect I don't know if you mind
repeating a little bit Eric so so pills
can contextualize because I'm gonna go
into delusion Marxism now
yeah I was comparing
um historical materialism using theology
as opposed to theology using historical
materialism but any means text the
Theses on history enacts that struggle
it's a Master Slave dialectic when
theology is on top
you have this situation that I just
compared to a certain reading of Freud
where Freud is a normalizer right you
take someone with a Neurosis you try to
give them the tools to handle that
neurosis and then insert them back into
society to become a productive member
good capitalist as opposed to the other
way around which you could say neuroses
is a fundamental constituent of our
subjectivity and you should accept that
you know being you know being different
is what gives you your unique
perspective in a certain more in a more
self-help sound bite kind of way right
yeah and my in my segue to go into the
loose from here bills and I would love
to hear your take from this because it's
a Pity that we never got the loser marks
I think is one of my biggest bone
killers in the history history of
intellectual work but I think I think
there's a relationship here in the
critique that loses to psychoanalysis in
the sense that this founding meets that
in a way Freud went all the way back as
much as he could to find these
structures as a reflection of psyche
that is only materialized in the in the
repetition of these myths right so uh
Oedipus is nothing more than a
manifestation of something that we have
within our our structure of psycho of of
psyche that is tangibilized or in in
this relationship that we have with
family with others with libido with sex
with pleasure with Dura Sands with
permission and whatnot okay so what the
loose says is that is schizophrenics
when they are hallucinating they
hallucinate on everything
they don't hallucinate based on myths
like the Hallucination is completely uh
multi-rizoomatic you know Hallucination
is rhythmatic in in the sense that it
doesn't have a beginning point it
doesn't have a reference like
hallucination proves that our our free
our true free relation with the world is
rhizomatic in the sense that we can
dream about being a a plant and having a
Jewish stomach and you know like being
stolen during the night and going
everywhere with this this notion of
schizo but I think it's also a criticism
that Marx was being instrumentalized as
any theology can be instrumentalized to
sort of create a tangible human nature
and in human nature it's a fundamental
antagonism with dialectical materialism
because human nature doesn't it
pre-exists human it it it it's made
manifest in the work that we do with
nature we don't have accents Essence we
have existence We Exist first and then
Essence is produced and and
psychoanalysis tends to be essential in
the sense that it finds in Old
narratives these structures that
naturalize our behavior in the world and
this is anti-anti dialectical
materialism so that's why I think
there's some super strong insight into a
delusion reading from schizo analysis
analysis trying to think that every
theological structure tends to create a
naturalistic behavior a natural human
nature you know and this is completely
anti-anti Marxist
foreign
am I crazy here no no I I want to
respond to this but keeping the The
Listener in mind because you went uh
you're being
you're you're quite Advanced on this
point if we're doing reading metaphysics
I'm just a selfie stand like forgive me
I didn't study philosophy
also that's it
I never done a lesson in my life I would
like I would like to kind of pick up
three quarters of where you were there
in terms of the relationship between
capitalism and religion because you're
you're kind of saying that history
creates Not Human Nature in general but
human Nature's dependent on you know
what the material conditions are
demanding at the time exactly exactly
and we're talking about like
secularizing away from religion and then
maybe in the future we'll look back at
the the period of secularization
differently we don't know whatever
accidents happen but really the the
understanding of the liberal humanist
specifically Protestant Christian
I'm coming to see in my current work
largely as a product of capital
because in in Europe
the Catholic Church the monolithic
Catholic Church is the thing that is
like preventing free Exchange in the
15th 16th century because there's just
like for example you're not allowed to
lend money at interest
right
so usually right there's there's all
these rules that stop and like and like
the whole social safety net is dependent
on on on the church and you have to give
a certain amount of your money here so
what Luther and zwingli and these
reformers Calvin do is they make
religion just this closeted tiny little
personal experience personal
relationship with beard I really don't
need you don't need the social structure
you don't need the social the social
aspects of religion we need to break
that down and if you're if what you're
saying here is Right Diego they're not
resp they're not really believing this
they're doing this as unconscious agents
of a cybernetic deity called capitalism
just despite whatever reasons they give
yeah and they're going to give reasons
back and say oh you know what the
Catholic church is corrupt we need to
reduce power and influence we need to
return to the original meaning of how
about those indulgences hey those were
pretty those are exploitative you know I
made I made a I was into a tweets battle
yesterday I think and I was having a
discussion with a guy about the
definition of neoliberalism and my
different the one that currently works
for me the definition of liberalism is
the instrumentalization of the state to
further the product the the profit
motive so is using the state to advance
the product mode the profit motive this
is neoliberalism for me but then the guy
is uh he's an orthodoxist he said well
this is not new
the state has always been in work for
the productive motive I mean the state
is the one that gives property ownership
without the state there's no property
the only thing that I can attribute to
in a positive sense of you the notion of
property is the state so the state has
always been uh uh an agent of capital
and it's kind of true and I mean you
kind of you've kind of painted in your
video about capitalism starting in 1551
if I'm not wrong right with these first
Explorations right so so yes we have
always been neoliberal in if that's the
definition of neoliberalism but I I gave
a dialectical reading that is that okay
is liberalism was the the movement and
the division from the divine right of
kings from the state
but if you read it dialectically the
theological aspect was not super rated
as an empty negative but it was
integrated in service of what was
produced after the ashraven in the sense
that the new state that was created
after liberalism is a state that
includes theology as an agent to further
the productive motive but then
neoliberalism is the supervision of the
state to give more freedom to the
markets so then the state is is sublated
and it becomes an agent to further
improve the motives of capital but the
motive of capital was always the the one
that was moving history this this is
this is this is my reading of liberalism
as yes church is getting too powerful is
this getting in the way of Commerce so
we're gonna sublate it and we're gonna
dialectically go over it and make
theology work for Capital and then the
second movement on neoliberalism is that
the state is getting in front of capital
so so we need to sublate the state and
get it to work for capitalism this is my
reading of liberalism and then
neoliberalism
and then in the 70s and 80s you get
deregulation and and
Reagan Thatcher and all that sort of
yeah lazy Fair liberalism going uh
turned up to 110 yeah
yeah I get that pills what do you think
well I'm yeah I'm on this
I'm so obsessed right now with the idea
of limits and limits in capital because
I think the only thing that it observes
as a cybernetic system which is not
conscious yeah I mean it might be
conscious by extension through like
individual capitalists but not in the
first case but the program that it seeks
is where's the block where is the lawyer
overcome and it's the it's pure
rhizomatic yeah it finds it yeah and and
from these from these like temporary
centers of wealth accumulation which you
know Britain Holland at the beginning
United States now it just spreads out
and finds these things and it seems like
looking back like this happens
automatically there's this tentacle yeah
growth and there's no Restraint of
morality that morality is an
inconvenience obviously it doesn't
matter yeah but then yeah so my question
I guess to turn all this back is if
that's the thing that you're fighting
what do you do
with meaning
to
to I guess humanize that and this is why
I think humanism is a strategic response
not something I actually believe in but
something I think we almost need to
believe in because it's the only way to
introduce a value system that is foreign
to this logic that only seeks out
blockages right this is interesting
because my current reading is that and
this is a recent shift in my in my point
of view I think I went from being an
anti-capitalist which it I think is a
very infantile position now looking back
at myself uh to be in a post capitalist
and I think and this is more rigorous to
the materialist tradition in the sense
that capitalism is not something to be
antagonized capitalism is something that
will it loves antagonism yeah exactly
yeah it's almost like this sense that
what impedes the way becomes the way you
know whatever resistance you put in
front in front becomes the way of
expansion it's it's incredible you know
it's like this is a System Theory you
know like exactly where you set the
limit is is where it's going to exhaust
the the greater amounts of force to
overcome it yeah it's it's it's almost
counterintuitive to our notion of
resistance is is is is insane and like
the systematic reading of capitalism is
truly brutal because you show us our
importance in a way but what I'm saying
of being post-capitalist and I think
this is something that Engels mentioned
when he was confronted with this notion
that some primitive cultures were
communists and and of course they cannot
be Communists because communism can only
come after socialism and after
capitalism so there's no way for a
primitive organization of power or
social organization to be communist
doesn't make any sense communism
necessarily needs the unjust immoral
the predatory development of capitalism
I think all that is solid balanced into
air all that is sacred is profaned but
is it isn't that isn't that sentence
used in the sen in the sense of uh of a
compliment to capitalism yeah because it
dissolves the feudal order it dissolves
the authoritarian order yeah and
replaces it it's a it's a it's a
compliment to Bourgeois revolutionary
spirits in the sense that well
dialectics can only be taken serious if
you say the the the current state of of
things that we're living in is a is a is
a resolution from past antagonisms and
also I also I always love to remind me
this sentence from Hegel that was
recuperated by Marx and Engels that
everything that is real is rational and
what is rational is real but then angles
added what is real is rational and what
is rational can be real
you know this in the sense that it
doesn't it doesn't closes the loop but
it opens a possibility for rationality
if rationality is truly rational to
eventually become actualized in history
so in that sense my reading is that yes
we live in and not it's hard to make
these claims without moralizing but we
live in the only possible time
right like this is is almost
deterministic to say that there's
there's if if there are some
organizations of state power
accumulation and production is because
they're rational up to a certain sense
you either accept that or you marry
yourself to this notion that we're truly
free and that everything is spontaneous
and it was created out of volunteerism
and Free Will no it has to have a
certain level of rationality for it to
operate what we have to what we have to
understand and almost take a vow of a
vow of of humility is to say that things
will change when they're rational enough
to change so if if we're not ready to
overcome capitalism is because
capitalism hasn't give hasn't produced
everything that is able to produce in
the sense of of rationality and in the
sense of the logic of the material world
acting upon itself in a causal complex
sense do I hear some accelerationist
tones in there yeah step on it baby
well no it's it's not you know if what
we're saying is you know capitalism is
the most revolutionary mode of
production so far so far there's no we
yeah we're gonna have to out
revolutionize this extraordinarily
revolutionary regime and what I said
earlier about you know we need you know
we need we need to make room for meaning
and spiritualism and I'm trying to be
nice to the theological crowd saying
that but how like we do really have to
think hard about how you know
marrying Marxism to theology is going to
create some kind of context to I mean
out revolutionize capitalism because it
loves opposition right the limits you
set for it become the guiding principles
for the next step it doesn't take any
kind of limits or blockages it takes
those it co-ops them and it moves
forward and it moves up to the next
stage and yeah I mean accelerationism is
just about speeding up that process my
my only worry is really about you know
things like climate change and stuff
right you talk about materialistic basis
like it is accelerationism going to lead
to the failure of the material basis for
civilization in the first place then
where does Revolution go right we've got
heat waves in China we got Pakistan
underwater we got two massive hurricanes
hitting North America earthquakes yeah
you see the Swiss glaciers is [ __ ]
getting dissolved yeah and that's where
the flooding comes from but I mean
that's like kind of what it sounds like
Diego you might be saying is this it
will only change when it's rational for
it to change yep which and I I hate the
infantile
position of accelerationism insofar as
it says well we shouldn't do anything
then [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] it if it's if
it's [ __ ] it acceleration isn't then
just like go away
accelerationists are thinking about
Bitcoin and [ __ ] like that more more
than they're thinking about no no I
think those are those are like dumb
Libertarians they don't even know
they're just being milk out of their
money like [ __ ] idiots it's it's
insane it's the biggest pyramid scheme
in the story of the universe it's it's
ridiculous I mean if if all of
capitalism is a huge pyramid scheme like
nfts and crypto is like the pyramid
scheme the pyramid scheme of Our
Generation but but moving beyond that I
think like this even if if it's a naive
position to to assume a selectionism but
it pre-implies a notion of Freedom it
preemplies your Consciousness as an
active Agent of Change which is already
for me alive you know yeah I know that's
lib [ __ ] it's like your decisions matter
because you're you and you're special
you yeah it's like people saying like oh
my God if you're like at the moment that
I'm presenting my documentary about the
World Cup right so everybody's saying
like ah but if you're really against
Qatar and uh and you know the six six
thousand five hundred people died you
you should boycott the World Cup it's
like I don't believe in the market what
do you mean boycott that's [ __ ] dumb
it's like like to to think that my
decisions actually influence the market
is to be liberal like that's the worst
insult ever of course I don't believe in
the market it won't alter itself because
of my decision that's that's [ __ ]
it's like that's that's probably the
lowest you can get and in that sense I
think even being a Marxist it's kind of
hard that you have to to find your own
your own point of view about how much
you can influence the system back versus
how much your product of the system
itself and and this is this is my and I
think if I think that's totally true and
if you're honest you're always more a
product than you are a producer unless
you're rich it's exactly my point
exactly exactly my point pills so people
come back to this notion of uh are you
revolutionary reformist
it's like what do you mean reform is so
revolutionary like you have to determine
for me first if you're a product of the
system or if you're an agent in the
system because this is this is my issue
my latest arguments are always with
marxists that are in the in the in the
root idealists
and this I cannot stand and moralists
yeah and moralists and that is just this
is my my massive shift over the last six
months has been like your capitalists
are not bad they're not good they're not
bad you're not good because you're not a
capitalist you would be if you could be
you would be if you just had accumulated
General generational wealth you would be
exactly the same unconscious animal that
they are exactly yeah yeah I mean Marx
talks about this sort of thing the
exigencies of competition right if you
if you start bringing morals into the
way you run your business you're gonna
fail and you're going to descend into
poverty there's certain exigencies that
you just have to follow it's not it's
neither good nor bad it's just what is
there's no good nor bad thinking makes
it so yeah are we going to look back at
morals and times and say that moral was
the religion of our of Our Generation
I don't well I don't I'm back on
genealogy of morals which we opened up
this uh this episode with and you you
need an a plant needs an atmosphere
to grow you can't grow in a desert so
then I think what are we supposed to
make mess you know that's what I would
like
to be the goal to make better myths
their stories and maybe and maybe this
is where the loose wanted to take us in
the sense of how do we create the new
how do we produce how do we truly
produce the new and this is this is for
me a big big question
how are we able to not change in the
moralistic sense and I think this is is
almost where we ended our last
conversation as well pills without Eric
that I'm not worried in this moral point
of view and and understanding that my
son is condemned to homelessness and
living in the streets by the capitalist
logic and even even saying that I
understand that capitalism is not a
moral system
this is is not a moral failure to be
born unable to produce it's it's a
matter of efficiency it's a matter of
productivity that is it's a logic that
works within capital for the
accumulation of capital for the sake of
itself that that doesn't account for for
human capital and this is why I'm always
punching on this this button of of
raising Consciousness that we're no
longer humans under Capital we're human
capital like the the subcategory capital
is more important subcategory human
under the logic of the system itself and
even even understanding that my direct
family my my son is extremely fragile
within the system I understand that the
system is not to blame
in in the sense that this is not up it's
not a moral failing that I'm judging and
saying that ah we should be better we
should aim to prosper and to include
others it's like dude there's what do
you propose like what system is more
efficient at the moment
which which is the model which is the
most productive system in the history of
mankind to be to be a Marxist is also to
understand that there's nothing more
productive than capitalism what we have
to understand is like Eric said there's
limits to capitalism and how do we deal
with these limits how the limits propose
an alternative how the limits produce
further capitalism and and and how can
we use the creation of the new as
potential Alternatives as desirable
paths for the future and stuff
yeah that that is what makes me a little
annoyed about the moralistic or idealist
materialist position is that yeah you
can't bring morals into the picture when
we say things like you know Trump is an
aberration no Trump is Trump is
democracy an appendage of capitalism
working just as it should it's produced
its result that it is made to produce
it's not an aberration it's not an
anomaly it's working just fine and
that's how it's going it kind of annoys
me when it's like oh well we just have
to be more moralistic and teach voters
you know to vote with their vote with
their hearts rather than just
vote harder vote with your heart not
just your head right like I mean Ben you
mean saying here you know it's not it's
not a fight for the future it's a fight
for the past right it's a revolutionary
struggle as a fight for the past to
articulate he says that the thesis six
here you know to articulate the past
historically doesn't mean to recognize
it the way it is and it means to seize
hold of a memory as it flashes up in a
moment of danger
and there's a certain element of
messianism is about
the past and and then through that we
move into the future not about the fight
for the future is simple as if you know
events are this sort of linear
progression beads on a string
I want to reconnect this espinoza's
ideas of Freedom with the Benjamin's
reading of History
in the sense that so Spinoza readings of
Freedom are we're only free as we are
ignorant of the causes that produces us
and Benjamin says we will never be able
to produce the future unless we fully
reconcile the past
like it's it's almost there's there's
something there no there's am I crazy
there's there's a synchronicity I think
the connection there is on something
that we haven't brought up yet which is
labor
because Marx is a labor realist and I
think because of the way we have all
grown up we do not believe in the
reality of Labor or labor we believe in
Commodities we believe that Commodities
are things that can be sold like
regardless of Labor and I was thinking
about this earlier this week actually
the only place where we really consider
labor to be something real is in
intellectual production
like if you write a book
or make a make a YouTube video like you
do
no one thinks that that belongs to
somebody else when they when they come
into possession of it but if you buy
headphones or microphone or shoes you
think that that thing belongs to you now
not that it belongs to the labor that's
invested into it and you were saying
earlier of course
Capital doesn't capitalism doesn't give
a [ __ ] about you but it does care about
your energy yeah it cares about the
energy that it can extract from you and
our the
the ideology I think all of us believe
we're even knowing that it's incorrect
but we still believe it is you produce
something and now you know now it's no
longer yours so there's this division of
energy that you've expended really
materially truly energy has been moved
from you into a commodity into a product
and we disconnect those two things and
say you know now the product is like
self-caused as you're talking about in
the Spinoza sense it's on its own it's
not connected to all those that that
Network that generated it in the first
place and not just whoever sewed sewed
the shoe together but the global Network
that transported it from Vietnam to here
or whatever but we forget that labor is
real and I think that might be a first
stage to demystify
um
the the ideology that even I absolutely
believe without remembering that I
believe it yeah is the things that you
don't know you know so it's it's it's
interesting that you brought labor into
this and because you know like this
notion that the the dialectical part of
my of dialectical materialism is
antagonisms resolving themselves and um
there's one definition of truth from
Hegel that is in one of his texting
phenomenology that I really like is that
uh Freedom uh freedom is the attitude to
overcome that which impedes freedom
so freedom is the attitude to overcome
whatever limits freedom but but also
capitalism is the attitude of overcoming
Dutch with limits capitalism so there's
there's also a dialectical reading of
capitalism as these ever-growing machine
that grows where limits are imposing to
it it's it's almost like capitalism is
this the Geist manifesting itself and
dialectically overcoming whatever we try
to stop it you know there's there's a
[ __ ] up hegelian reading of capitalism
as a God that I will I would love to
explore into at some moment but what I
wanted to get into this is that this
notion that uh being being a Messianic
Orthodox is materialistic dialect
dialectical material is from Marxist
point of view story is fixing itself out
is figuring itself out as it at
antagonism clash and new Solutions are
going to evolve out of this out of these
antagonisms that are getting revolved so
labor right so you said when we produce
content
maybe the people that are seeing the
prod the product of our work of our
energy doesn't see our commodity as
being alienated because they cannot
separate the the production of our labor
from the mer from the merchandise so
already a part of the alienation was
solved
maybe we still feel alienated because we
know YouTube is keeping 30 of what you
make so you feel kind of robbed and and
you don't fully recognize yourself in
the result of your work but a part of
the of the the four types of alienation
presented by Marx one of them maybe was
resolved within the production of
capital
like within Capital we gave birth to
these content platforms that monetize
our time directly but by monetizing our
time directly they overcome one of the
alienations uh antagonisms that was the
alienation between we don't see the the
labor force in the merchandise that we
consume you see and maybe and I'm not
dreaming not being Messianic but maybe
this is this is the dwarf under the
table
the dwarf under the table is how new
technologies will eventually even if by
mistake the resolution of set
antagonisms that then will be signified
as a new a new moment in history
I mean I don't I I don't think it's
arguable that I feel less alienated
editing my videos then putting roofs on
Cedar roofs on rich people's houses yeah
but that's the the type of alienation
where you don't own the product of your
labor you don't see yourself in it it
appears in the marketplace as something
foreign to you and your labor which
originally produced it now this collapse
of time in space actually closes that
distance a little bit it doesn't it
doesn't help the alienation it's still
not you it's still not yours but it's
much closer we can see what it's doing
we can see what's happening and I I
gladly give my time and my energy to
these things because that's what you
know that's what we need to do I I guess
I I just like to be closer to it and
that's my that's my my idea that doesn't
matter these are my ideas that don't
matter but at least I get to see them
and I get to see the metrics and I get
to see the reactions
but but then but then you see Eric my
point was that um and correct me for
wrong the four types of admiration is
alienated to Nature alienated to
yourself alienated to order to others
and alienator to work
or what was the fourth one product of
labor and the the product of labor okay
so you see so okay so we're still
annihilated from nature very much
we're still alienated from the product
of our work because even us as creators
you see yourself but you don't fully
recognize yourself in the result of your
labor like this part of violation I
still feel kind of there but alienation
from others this is where I find
interesting about about what you said
appeals is that even if I don't fully
recognize myself in the result of my
work because as Eric said there's some
degree of alienation that is not
resolved people don't alienate the fruit
of my work from myself anymore right
that that if we break it down in four
parts that part of alienation at least
is is change is different it's less than
that the very least yeah and as learning
said like the process of dialectical
materialism of becoming post-capitalist
it could be centuries mm-hmm I don't
know if you can survive it but yeah no
we we think you know if if 1844 Marx was
about disalienation whereas Das Capital
marks is is not an accelerationist but
closer to that position where it
capitalism's internal contradictions
have to play out yeah and so that that's
where I don't know if I want to go
straight accelerationism okay yeah
accelerate these internal contradictions
right what what happens if time and
space collapses and we at least
stop recognize we don't recognize
ourselves in the product doesn't resolve
that but there is still a certain
immediacy to it to it is that it is that
the process that's that's the process
that is happening and then you have sort
of
I guess the bigger picture comes from
like Janis farafaka's talking about like
platform techno feudalism that is that's
the next phase that we're speeding
towards that and we're in a new kind of
feudalistic next phase and so I really
accelerate I want to talk about this for
a second because I don't know if it's
right to say that it's feudalism which
makes it sound like we're going back but
really I think what's happening when we
say like the rent economy is capitalism
is running into a final limit which is
the liberal humanist individual and so
far we're thinking yeah so far we've
been thinking oh no liberal humanism and
capitalism they work great together but
capitalism reached its new limit it's
found you as an individual it's saying
no now I'm going to mine your eyeballs
I'm going to creep down your brain stem
modify your your attention I don't get
you to work harder I don't give a [ __ ]
if there's an individual here or not
you're you're now just a rent machine so
I think we're running to that
contradiction and then like the question
is what's next of course we're running
into a limit I think so what will be
cool here is is well looking at
literature and entertainment the way we
dream about the future not about these
Notions of cyberpunk and uh
post-apocalyptic words and whatnot I
think we haven't been able to fully
embrace the nightmare of post-human
capitalism
you know like the the true nightmare of
post-human capitalism you know like this
this uh we see it in cracks yeah and we
still think we're gonna survive it
that's it ideology yeah yeah exactly
that's that's liberalism that's
liberalism to blame because this
liberalism still thinks uh capitalism is
working out of human human Freedom
that's the problem they don't see
capitalism as a system as a
self-sufficient system and an
independent system with its own logic
and its own set of goals they see
capitalism as a manifestation of Human
Action this is is the this is the
fundamental problem they believe in
axioms for God's sakes is it's beyond
dumb it's beyond dumb it's like it's
dangerously dumb and and it drive like
privacy and in the sense of personal
ownership you do not own your own
attention anymore like consider that
what do you think what is you if you
don't own your attention they have
created this notion that there's a drug
that can make you feel like a second was
I think a hundred years right so the the
first thing we can think of the first
we're gonna use that to to punish
prisoners and to shorten your sentences
and still condemn you to labor and to
make you like experience reality is this
fictional no this is not fictional holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah this is this is why I
think people haven't taken seriously
enough that the the nightmare of of
post-human capitalism like people who
have no idea what it's like to be
drugged out of your bed to produce until
the point that you're needed and then
you're loan no longer needed and you're
worth less than Caldo
you know it's it's this we we cannot
even fathom the the notion of amoral
systems because we are so
anthropocentric
yes
it's like a dream or the moment of death
there's like a A Thousand Years could be
just packed into that all right but a
drug to induce that
no no it's insane that's something else
yeah this and this is and this is for me
the limit the limit is um if I'm tired
and again this is where you fall in this
ambiguous line am I a religious
communist religious in the sense that I
think communism is a world view that
explains everything and it's going to
figure itself out even if I don't act
like am I am I that type of religious
communist I take communism as a religion
that is over determining itself to
overcome capitalism eventually or like
do I have to take it seriously enough to
also embrace the fact that humans are
not necessarily part of the equation
that's a nice thought yeah I'm not ready
to go there yeah yeah [ __ ] that man yeah
I I hope I'm dead way before those
things come out like really because I am
philosophically speaking I am a
post-humanist but I don't even want to
imagine that because it's too terrifying
yeah it is I think which is
Only a God can save us I think I'd agree
have you responds to that have you seen
this new anime from Netflix uh cyberpunk
70 27 7.
[Music]
yeah it's based on a video game I I
didn't play the game but I watched the
anime because it's from one of my
favorite Studios from Japan trigger
Studios their art style is
out of this [ __ ] world I swear to God
it's the the best that I've seen in TV
for a very very long time even just
because of the art style it's worth
watching but it touches on some trance
and post-humanist topics that are quite
interesting like you know these Paradox
of the ship of the cells
we have changed the piece we have
repaired the ship so many times and we
have changed the pieces so many times
that how can we tell if the same if the
same ship right if the same ship so I
think this this notion comes back to to
what we understand and a key part of the
myopic point of view of liberalism as
they they don't fully they don't fully
embrace the notion that even humans are
um
how can I say this if ethereal in yeah I
think they believe in the
how do I put this sorry I was like all
coming in here hot like I don't know
what I'm gonna say no but I'm missing
they believe they believe in the
morality of capitalism really at bottom
they're like okay it's gonna go this far
but no further whereas I think if you
really understand what an amoral system
is you were just you're gonna dissolve
you are gonna become the limit that the
church used to be and it will dissolve
you break you into parts and you'll be
like just an extraneous little bump
sport sitting around waiting for some
waiting and it'll use you to do
something it'll need you for something
discard you yeah whatever I I I I almost
could listen to these liberals snowflake
in my mind saying my boss is not bad
it's not that bad you know it's like the
the boot that steps on me is not that
heavy bro it's super heavy you have no
idea it's gonna stomp you so hard you
have no clue but it's almost like do
they enjoy it in the Azure science type
of way
I think you I think you would call that
pure ideology
yeah it's not saying your symptom yeah
enjoy your symptoms
in a sense it is true though like the
the suffering
is profound but not profound enough for
us to think this is the only thing that
matters
like when when when peasants are
starving they don't care about their
life enough to keep it right and like I
don't know
18th century France right yeah like if
you're starving it doesn't matter if you
die so until we're starving we'll just
let that rent out our head and
eventually that contradiction will reach
reach its uh culmination and it always
bring us to the question it will it be
soon enough like like for example where
do you do manifestations today you know
doing manifestations on the streets is
[ __ ] worthless nothing happens on the
streets like soon there will be no
buildings to manifest in front of like
what do you do cancel politicians in
Twitter it's like that's your last line
of resistance it's so pathetic it's like
oh my God I don't know like it gives me
the grips to think that um when we
reaches the point where dialectically
capitalism as this Geist that is
overcoming whatever limits it is is is
needing to overcome us as the final
barrier to be overcome we won't have any
tools of resistance
in the very delusion sense yeah I think
another angle I was just thinking of
with through all that too is that our
heads are spaces for rent for ideas in
the sense that you know
like glittery and the the production of
subjectivity right we've been talking a
lot like like the bass and the
superstructure are two separate things
and really when you think about the
production of subjectivities
subjectivity
you know ideas are just squatting in our
heads in a certain way we're giving free
rent space to ideas and subjectivities
uh that night that nice book Maurizio
lacerato writes about gutari and and
that seems relevant to me if if
subjectivity is produced
whereas on the other hand liberalism is
is kind of on ego egoistic it's we are
rational self-possessed individuals who
are almost present at our own birth in a
certain way no that's not the case we're
almost we're almost born I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say tabula Raza but we are
subjects that are produced for Capital
to then exploit in the future we are
shaped and we have to break out of that
in a certain sense or maybe maybe
wouldn't be prescriptive like that but
that's not tabular rasa but I think it's
like inarguable to say we're already
born in motion we're born in a
trajectory you're not born sitting still
before some causes come and affect you
you're you're born in motion yeah yeah
like the process relational kind of view
as opposed to just the egotistical view
where it's like I am my own person yeah
and if you're born on an accumulated uh
grab a well of wealth then your life
will be very different than if you're
not born with that and that's that's
really not that much up to you in the
end one of my my dream projects is to
research the use of corn in Latin
America as a big aerogenetic product uh
project to dump people down
corn corn is the next after your
football documentary maybe I would love
to research the effect of over
consumption of corn in Latin America to
make people stupid
wait what this is an epigenetic effect
yeah corn makes you dumber oh yeah the
corn is is barely non-eatable for humans
oh wow we're back to Corn Flakes again
then oh yeah of course we're back
yes and we're at biosemiotics yeah but
but absolutely Eric in the sense that
you know like for example because of my
son my wife and she's [ __ ] brilliant
I would love for you guys to talk to her
sometime even if she doesn't give
interview because of her practice she
has no public figure at all she takes
psychoanalysis very very seriously but
she went into epigenetics because of my
son's disease like we started looking at
his behavior from psychoanalysis and it
was a dead end you know this he has no
language what do you do so we went into
epigenetics and biomedicine and and
predictive medicine so we change his
diet we went with nutritionists with uh
endocrinologists with epigeneticians and
we changed like supplements and what he
eats and whatnot he started speaking
that's amazing and that and that and
that's the amazing thing about
epigenetics and the way that you know
neo-darwinism has colonized our view of
biology right and it it takes out what's
his name not Darwin but the other guy
Lamarck right Lamarck had the ideas that
within your lifetime certain things
could be produced that would be then
passed down rather than you know
whatever Richard Dawkins the selfish
Gene kind of theory where epigenetics is
not an option in that point of view I
guess I guess there's a certain amount
of scientific literacy that's going to
be needed to develop among people too in
order to sort out which ideas are really
new epigenetics is something that's
fascinating and interesting whereas you
know the neo-darwinists and the
followers of Richard Dawkins need to
just go
stop talking you know just to clarify so
when I say he's he started speaking like
still his his vocabulary super super
limited but we solved progresses in his
cognitive abilities so this is my point
like okay let's say we're not we're not
free to ideologically change the world
but out of the efficiency of capital of
feeding Mass workers with whatever was
the cheapest available option we produce
subjectivity that are our physical
consequence of the consumption of corn
I don't want to touch that why not
because I don't know anything about it
yeah
and that sounds
compelling but yeah that's why that's
why I'm saying it's one of my dream
projects to research that
to say if how to to what point because
we know it's true that your food Alters
your psyche your mood your your
predisposition to the world I mean come
on we're researching now the effects of
early Alzheimer's in people with
diabetes and it's related to to Sugar
you know of of course our what we put
into our body changes our not our psyche
it's more like our ability to produce a
subjectivity so in that sense I would
love to go into detail and to see how
even if it was not out of pure intention
we created a whole series of
subjectivities that are consequence of
material conditions out of mistakes of
our interpretation of freedom but it was
truly the intention of capital acting
through Us in maximizing profitability
work and feeding people with something
that is cheap
I really like this idea not knowing any
details but I really like the idea of
pointing out these sites that are in
plain sight like corn is one of the most
and not just not just people eating corn
but like livestock and animals most of
what they eat is corn it's not the best
thing for them to eat it's much better
for them to eat in grass so all of this
comes to a head at this little site and
I really like these investigative
projects you did one with football and
we'll look forward to that next one and
we'll win again you should just keep
coming back every month Diego yeah man I
love it these are the best conversations
ever I would love to go on about it
right because corn is a system effect
someone I haven't brought up before but
Jason Moore right the chiefs of
capitalism right and it's a system
effect we we moved to industrialism they
prefer cheap cheap nature what do we get
in all of our industrial kitchens now we
get salt we get sugar we get those cheap
flavorful things
yeah
is sugar it has the same
oh yeah like intentionally modified yeah
domesticated product yeah right now 99
of the human consumption of corn is from
one species that is Created from
Monsanto we almost eradicated all corn
varieties around the world for one of
them that is the most resistance and the
easiest to replicate the decision is
purely is purely within the logic of
capital purely within the logical yeah
oh yeah yeah and it's making us all it's
it's it's having a deleterious effect to
say the least insulin resistance you
know it's killing my because uh
microbiota like the the the diversity of
bacteria in your gut and all in all your
body is dependent on diversity but
because we tend to eat because of
efficiency of capital specific types of
food it leads to the diminishing effect
of having a variety of bacteria but in
the end this is like the
counter-intuitive reading of complexity
theory if complexity leads to complexity
the uncomplexed system of of bacteria in
your gut can lead to uncomplexed outcome
of subjectivity of course this is me
being completely ludicrous doing these
ideological reading of material
conditions but but but for sure there's
a there's a chemical argument to be made
yeah I think you're on to something to
there definitely you know mono cropping
genetic simplification the GMOs in order
to be more resistant to certain
pesticides which then brings more mono
cropping and genetic simplification than
suddenly everything is just one type of
corn and even if we become corn people
yeah we become corn people and even if
you're skeptical about the epigenetic
like effects of corn on your conscious
what what you are doing in effect from a
complexity
Theory perspective is limiting the
potential for any accidents to happen
which changes which makes like reality
more predictable which is what
capitalism wants it wants prediction it
wants the easiest map the easiest causal
relationship you see this and you react
in a predictable way but anyway guys we
are we need to have this conversation
with Martin Vic I would love to have the
Liberals on this there's so many things
I would love to bring up and see their
point of view
foreign
I used to be a dungeon master when I was
younger yes
yes
guys we're getting it going again is
there anything else you want to uh Point
people towards Diego before we wrap up
we're at absolutely we passed an hour
and a half past I will Point them
towards past episodes of the peel pod
that's all thank you no come on you're
too kind no you guys are you guys are
[ __ ] awesome Beyond Comprehension to
be honest with you like I just did this
event in in Mexico City and I brought my
friends from other countries just for
the sake and the pleasure of seeing them
in person and having 24-hour discussions
about super complex topics which was
[ __ ] amazing and I'm just now
releasing the podcast that we recorded
because I rented a a tower like a
four-story building and I put each of
them in one apartment and one apartment
I transform into a studio so what we did
is that every day we recorded Like
permutating A and B A and C A and D like
and then all of us together and then we
did one one live event with almost a
thousand people in Mexico City to
discuss about uh what does it mean first
to be Latin and we even bought up the
point that Quebec could be part of Latin
America
oh
excellent I think that's something our
listeners should check out big time yeah
but it's an interesting argument isn't
it yeah
I mean the the Latin language influences
I mean depends on how you determine what
is Latin America but
you could you could argue because they
are Latin and they are in America I like
it I think Quebec should separate
romantic at least I don't know if
they're like for sure and I would love
to have you guys on my channel as well
even if most of my my crowd speak
Spanish most of them speak English as
well so anytime you guys want to come
along as Standalone characters avatars
or as a group of individuals which I I I
tend to believe that you guys exist in
real life I think I'm right so there's
no proof but I think I'm right if you
guys want to come you're super invited
as well oh yeah that's how we know we're
here in Ontario it's a big horrible
Beast sucks up Quebec's goodness and it
feeds off western Canada and we're
hungry for for that nice antibasca oil
fields of the colonial project by taking
over taking over Latin American YouTube
oh my God yeah that's that's the that's
it that's a project that's a true
project now you show your tentacles
pills first corn then Latin American
YouTube
Ontario hungry I will with that I will
uh end the recording thank you to all
the listeners for uh coming thanks Eric
and Diego you'll just you just gotta
keep coming back absolutely we'll make
it a regular thing all right goodbye
everybody all right
[Music]